[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers
in allen guten Abend an einem Tag an dem
viele entscheidende Fragen offen sind
wird auch Deutschland Kampfpanzer
liefern in die Ukraine sowie es
Verbündete vormachen und damit den Druck
Richtung Berlin erhöhen dann wann kommt
die Zeitenwende bei der Bundeswehr an
die nach wie vor mit absurden Zuständen
kämpft und wer hat eigentlich künftig
die befehls- und Kommando Gewalt bei der
Armee wenn die jetzige
Verteidigungsministerin dann auch
öffentlich ihren Rücktritt erklärt wovon
sie in Berlin quer durch die Bank
ausgehen
hinter den Kulissen gibt es viele
Gerüchte es dürfte und müsste eigentlich
jetzt echte Bemühungen geben dafür
Klarheit zu sorgen Frank Buchwald
noch Licht im Kanzleramt der Chef so
heißt es in Berlin hinter vorgehaltener
Hand berate im kleinen Kreis über das
Schicksal von Christine Lambrecht wann
und wo weiß keiner so genau noch ist die
Verteidigungsministerin im Amt ihr
Rücktritt gilt als ausgemacht der
SPD-Chef aber hält sich bedeckt ich
kommentiere Zeitungsartikel nicht aber
in einer Sache können Sie im Grundsatz
ausgehen das was wir als SPD zu
entscheiden haben das entscheiden wir
geschlossen mit dem Bundeskanzler
zusammen mit der Parteiführung mit dem
Fraktionsvorsitzenden und wir verkünden
Dinge dann wenn sie zu verkünden sind
Stiefel Panzer und flektar das war wohl
nie die Welt der Christine Lambrecht
Verteidigung aber viel über die SPD und
es musste eine Frau sein wegen der
Parität nun jedoch so die Opposition
sollte Scholz nach anderen Kriterien
entscheiden
jetzt muss es um Sachkompetenz gehen
jetzt braucht das
Bundesverteidigungsministerium jetzt
braucht die Bundeswehr eine Person an
der Spitze die mit Kompetenz und
Herzblut die Aufgaben angeht aus der
Koalition kommen ähnliche Signale Sarah
Nanni verteidigungsexpertin der Grünen
ließ wissen es gehen nun vor allem um
eine schnelle Entscheidung nicht um
Parität ähnlich argumentiert FDP viel zu
Kubicki der Bundeskanzler sollte das für
Deutschland Sicherheit wichtige
Verteidigungsministerium nicht unter
paritätischen Gesichtspunkten nach
Geschlechtern sondern nur nach Kompetenz
besetzen viel Zeit bleibt im Kanzler
nicht schon nächsten Freitag ist in
Ramsteiner NATO Spitzentreffen geplant
dort soll es um Hilfe für die Ukraine
gehen auch mit Kampfpanzern Deutschland
zögert die Verbündeten aber erwarten
mehr der Eindruck von außen der entsteht
ist immer dass Deutschland gedrängt wird
etwas zu tun und eben nicht freiwillig
den nächsten Schritt geht und das immer
erst dann macht wenn sich andere
auch bewegt haben und eben nicht sich
eine Spitze einer Bewegung setzt und
andere Staaten mitnimmt Scholz steht
deshalb auch international unter Druck
dutzende Kampfpanzer vom Typ Leopard
warten eingemottet in einer Halle bei
Flensburg so schnell aber werden sie
wohl nicht einsatzbereit sein sagt der
Chef des Herstellers reinmetall selbst
wenn morgen die Entscheidung fällt dass
wir unsere Leopard-Panzer nach Kiew
schicken dürfen dauert die Lieferung bis
Anfang nächsten Jahres
von einer solchen Entscheidung aber kann
im Kanzleramt bisher keine Rede sein und
so könnte die Zeiten Wände von der
Scholz im Februar letzten Jahres
gesprochen hatte auch personell im
deutschen Harmoniebedürfnis stecken
bleiben
dann gucken wir noch kurz nach Berlin zu
Theo Koll und am Theo das ist ja eine
einigermaßen absurde Situation jetzt es
wirkt irgendwie wie ein Abgang in
Zeitlupe und das in diesen Zeiten wie
stellt sich der Bundeskanzler denn das
weitere Vorgehen vor
ich glaube es dürfte das Ende der
Zeitlupe gekommen sein und eine rasche
Erklärung ins Haus stehen denn ansonsten
landet natürlich jedes weitere zögern
dann auch als führungsversagen oder
Führungsschwäche direkt hier beim
Kanzler Donnerstag und Freitag kommt du
weißt Verteidigungsminister dann muss
die deutsche Seite sprechen und
vertretungsfähig sein und die Hinweise
dass sich führen der SPD Vertreter
inklusive Kanzler heute abend abstimmen
wollten oder abgestimmt haben wurden
jedenfalls von keinem der infrage
kommenden dementiert das spricht also
vieles dafür dass der morgige Tag der
letzte Montag der
Verteidigungsministerin Lambrecht sein
dürfte dann lass uns hier doch bitte
noch ein bisschen übernahmen und die
damit verbundenen Folgen reden wie
könnte denn eine Nachfolgeregelung
abziehen
also der Ukraine Krieg und die
zeitenwände die haben ja einerseits die
Bedeutung des Verteidigungsministeriums
massiv erhöht und andererseits wurden
auch durch lambrechtsschwäche ja viele
Entscheidungen hier ins Kanzleramt
verlagert die Nachfolgeregelung wird
also auch darüber entscheiden wie viel
Verteidigungs wie viel
Sicherheitspolitik der Kanzler künftig
selbst machen will wenn er wie von
vielen gefordert jetzt ein politisches
Schwergewicht für die Lambrecht
Nachfolge holt also beispielsweise
Arbeitsminister Heil oder SPD-Chef
klingen weil werden genannt dann würde
er zwar angemessenerweise das
Verteidigungsministerium stärken aber
erreicht damit dann an anderer Stelle
große Löcher die Nachfolge Regelung geht
in jedem Fall also über die reine
Personalie Lambrecht hinaus Theo vielen
Dank für diese Analyse live aus Berlin
und wir bleiben noch beim Thema andere
Wüsten heißt der Chef des
Bundeswehrverbandes und jetzt bei uns
guten Abend
schönen guten Abend Herr Sievers es
heißt Ministerin Lambrecht habe es nie
wirklich geschafft Vertrauen und Ansehen
bei der Truppe zu gewinnen was müsste
denn eine Nachfolgerin ein Nachfolger
anders machen eine gute und richtige
Frage ist wie wir es lassen Sie mich
vorweg sagen mit Blick auf das was
bisher kommuniziert wurde ich zolle der
Minister und Respekt für diesen Schritt
sie und ich wir wissen Rücktritte sind
in der Vergangenheit nicht mehr in der
Tagesordnung gewesen und deswegen
Respekt dafür nach vorne zurück tritt
das ist ja bisher noch gar nicht
offiziell haben sie da mehr Information
wurde gehe ich davon aus dass es so
erfolgen wird alles andere würde mich
stark verwundern jetzt der Blick nach
vorne Ihre Frage was braucht eine
einkünftige Minister er braucht
Kompetenz er braucht
Durchsetzungsvermögen er muss
parteiübergreifend anerkannt sein und ja
er muss auch integrieren können er steht
vor einer enorm Herausforderung das
Verteidigungsministerium ist von Hause
aus schon das schwierigste Ministerium
in der Bundesregierung und das
insbesondere Mahlzeiten jetzt haben wir
ja gerade ein interessanten Aspekt bei
Theo Koll gehört vor zwei Minuten die
Ministerin Lambrecht war immer loyal zum
Bundeskanzler und hat es offenbar auch
hingenommen wenn wichtige
bundeswehrentscheidungen dort fielen
nämlich beim Bundeskanzler und nicht in
ihrem Ministerium ist das aus ihrer
Sicht ein Vorteil oder ein Problem ich
gehe davon aus dass auch in Zukunft
wichtige Entscheidungen im Kanzleramt
getroffen werden und auch werden müssen
wir haben Krieg in Europa und wir sind
in der schwierigen Situation da braucht
es eine breite Abstimmung mit dem
Kanzler aber auch in der gesamten
Bundesregierung ob es um Waffenlieferung
geht oder auch um die Finanzierung der
Bundeswehr da reicht es nicht allein
dass eine Verteidigungsministerin ein
Verteidigungsminister in seinem Ressort
vor sich hin werkelt jetzt haben sie
mehrere
verteidigungsministerinnen erlebt in
ihrem Amt aktuell auch viel scheitern
erlebt das Amt gilt als Schleudersitz
gucken wir noch mal ein bisschen weiter
zurück zu Peter Druck der nie gedient
hatte und in der Truppe sehr beliebt
wurde was kann man von ihm lernen
er hat zugehört Authentizität er hat den
genalen zugehört er hat seine eigenen
Entscheidungen vorbereitet auch
getroffen er hat Linie gehalten aber
durchsetzungsfähig und er hat vor allem
kommuniziert auch in den
parlamentarischen Raum hat mitgenommen
jetzt beispielsweise für die Zukunft wer
elementar wichtig dass der nächste
Verteidigungsminister der nächste
Verteidigungsministerin klar aufzeigt
wie die Lage in der Bundeswehr ist wie
prekärse ist und dann das Parlament
mitzunehmen wenn es um Reform geht um
Veränderung in der Bundeswehr und ja
auch um mehr Investitionen da haben sie
jetzt schon angesprochen fast ein Jahr
nach der Zeitenwende ist ausgerechnet
der Zustand unserer Armee immer noch
marode wieso kommt denn von diesen 100
Milliarden sonderschulden so wenig an
liegt das auch an lambrecht
nein ich glaube es liegt an der Politik
in Gänze an der Bundesregierung auch mit
am Parlament wir haben zwar
unwahrscheinlich viel Rückendeckung aber
es muss verstanden werden dass wir Blick
auf die Geschwindigkeit die es jetzt an
den Tag zu legen geht wenn wir die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit stärken wollen
dass wir anders denken und handeln
müssen wir müssen rechtliche Normen noch
verändern wir müssen anderen Umgang mit
der Rüstungsindustrie pflegen wir müssen
out of the box denken ich nenne jetzt
mal ein Beispiel wenn wir jetzt Waffen
liefern wollen weiterhin wenn wir
weiterhin abschreckungsfähigkeit
erzeugen wollen wer hafter werden sollen
dann geht das nicht im alten System der
Kameralistik dann muss man mit
Mittelstand und Industrie über große
Linien sprechen damit die jetzt
einkaufen Rohstoffe Elektrik Elektronik
Bauteile und vieles mehr damit wir sagen
können sicher in den nächsten Jahren
wird Material zu laufen wenn wir das
machen im Altsystem wird das nicht
funktionieren und deswegen braucht es
eine neue denke im Umgang mit Industrie
mit Verteidigung mit allem was
dazugehört neue denke eben nicht nur bei
künftiger Ministerin künftige Minister
geht es denn wenigstens von der oben
Richtung damit wir da mal so einen
Eindruck gewinnen in die richtige
Richtung aus ihrer Sicht ist vor einigen
Monaten was ja immer so dass der
heeresinspektor sagte wir stehen nackt
da sie haben danach gesagt wir sind bald
splitterfasernackt das klingt ja eher
nach Rückschritt ja so können wir es
aktuell definitiv beschreiben das hängt
nicht damit zusammen dass wir
beispielsweise bestimmte Leistungen an
der NATO Nordost Flanke nicht mehr ja
vollziehen können ableisten abbringen
können sondern im Wesentlich geht es
darum dass wir ja mit Blick auf die
Lieferung an der Ukraine uns weiter leer
machen diese Lieferung sind sicherlich
notwendig auch zweckmäßig aber es wird
eben versäumt schnell nachzubestellen
Stichwort atherie Systeme jetzt wenn es
um den Schützenpanzer Marder geht wir
können ja nicht zusehen dass die
Bundeswehr weiter leer läuft in der
aktuellen Lage so müssen parallel eben
schnell und schneller beschaffen als
bisher das ist der das Gebot der Stunde
und dazu muss verstanden werden dass
auch das Sondervermögen bei weitem nicht
reichen wird
sagt André Wüstner Oberst andere Wüstner
vom Bundeswehrverband ich danke Ihnen
herzlich für das Gespräch heute abend
danke ebenso
ja das wollen ist da allein am können
mangelt ist Schutzwesten
nachtsichtbrillen Funkgeräte selbst bei
diesen vergleichsweise unkomplizierten
Dingen hängt die Beschaffung dramatisch
hinterher
Kampfpanzer aus Deutschland an die
Ukraine auch das wird ja laut Hersteller
offenbar noch ein Jahr dauern selbst
wenn jetzt eine schnelle Entscheidung
viele die Briten sind deutlich schneller
sie wollen schon in den kommenden Wochen
14 Kampfpanzer Challenger 2 in die
Ukraine schicken
wo der russische Terror weitergeht in
niebro haben sie mittlerweile 30
Menschen tot aus den Trümmern eines
Hochhauses geborgen das Ziel eines
raketenangriffs der Russen war viele
weitere Bewohner werden noch vermisst es
gibt nach wie vor verzweifelte Rufe aus
den Trümmern Tim Krüger
es ist ein kleines Wunder als
Hilfskräfte eine Frau lebend aus dem
zerstörten gebäudebergen wenigstens ein
Erfolg für Sie die seit gestern Abend
versuchen verschüttete aus den Trümmern
zu retten denn die Zahl der Opfer in
libro steigt den ganzen Tag Stunde um
Stunde die Luftaufnahmen vom
Einschlagsort des russischen
Marschflugkörper sind erschüttern eine
Mutter klagt an
warum hast du ihn getötet
ihr seid früher in unsere Stadt gekommen
und wir haben euch als Gäste empfangen
als normale Menschen als normale
Verwandte was habt ihr meinem Sohn
angetan ihr schoben
noch immer sollen viele unter den
Trümmern liegen aber die Hoffnung
weitere Menschen lieben zu finden
schwindet zu der Bürgermeister die
Überlebenden traumatisiert
ich weiß nicht vielleicht können uns
westliche Partner mit Systemen helfen
diese Raketen zu stoppen was soll so
etwas es gibt keine einzige
Militäreinrichtung hier
unter den Opfern sind auch Kinder ein
15-jähriges Mädchen ist unter den Toten
allein sieben Kinder wurden so schwer
verletzt dass sie ins Krankenhaus
eingeliefert werden mussten
ein neun Jahre altes Mädchen wurde
gebracht sie hat schwere Verletzungen
eine davon wurde durch die
Explosionswelle verursacht
sie hat außerdem eine
Gehirnerschütterung zwei gebrochene
Rippen und eine schrapnellverletzung am
Schienbein
es ist die bislang schwerste
Angriffswelle in der Ukraine in diesem
Jahr auch die Infrastruktur wurde erneut
angegriffen die Folge Stromengpässe in
vielen Landesteilen das russische
Verteidigungsministerium bestätigt die
Attacken am 14 Januar 2023 wurden
Raketenangriffe durchgeführt gegen
Militär und mit ihnen verbundene
Infrastruktureinrichtungen der Ukraine
alle ausgewählten Ziele wurden getroffen
kein Wort aber zu der verheerenden
Attacke auf Zivilisten mit so vielen
Toten und Verletzten in Nico und die
Suche nach den Opfern weitergeht
die weitere Weltlage heute abend hast du
jetzt im Blick Hannah na da schauen wir
zuerst auf Nepal dort sind bei einem
Flugzeugabsturz mindestens 68 Menschen
getötet worden vier werden vermisst die
Passagiermaschine von Yeti Airlines war
auf dem Weg von Kathmandu nach pokara
einem beliebten Touristenziel das
Unglück ereignete sich im Landeanflug
die Ursache ist noch unklar an Bord
waren laut Airline auch 15 Ausländer
unter anderem aus Frankreich Irland und
Indien wo Cara ist Ausgangspunkt für
zahlreiche tracking-touren
die Räumung des Ortes lützerath im
rheinischen Braunkohle Revier ist von
polizeilicher Seite offiziell
abgeschlossen alle noch verbliebenen
Demonstranten seien von Bäumen
heruntergeholt worden sagte ein
Polizeisprecher derzeit befänden sich in
den unterirdischen Tunneln noch zwei
Menschen und die sich nun aber der
Energiekonzern RWE kümmere nach der
Großkundgebung gestern warfen sich
Polizei und klimaaktivisten heute
gegenseitig Gewalttätigkeit vor die
Aktivisten kritisierten ein zu hartes
Vorgehen der Polizei diese sprach von 70
verletzten Beamten seit Beginn der
Räumung
um den Bundestag wieder auf seine
Regelgröße von 598 zu verkleinern hat
die ampelfraktion einen Gesetzentwurf
zur Wahlrechtsreform vorgelegt dieser
sieht vor dass es künftig keine Überhang
und Ausgleichsmandate mehr geben soll
Kandidaten die einen Wahlkreis direkt
gewinnen hätten somit keine Garantie
mehr in den Bundestag einzuziehen schon
lange streiten die Parteien über eine
Reform des Wahlrechts zuletzt war der
Bundestag auf eine Rekordzahl von 736
Abgeordneten gewachsen
in deutschland droht mehr als jeder
dritten Frau mit einer Vollzeitstelle
auch nach 40 Arbeitsjahren eine Rente
von unter 1.000 Euro im Monat das ist
das Ergebnis einer Anfrage der Linken
beim Bundesarbeitsministerium über das
das redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland
berichtet betroffen sein 2,7 Millionen
Vollzeitbeschäftigte Frauen um auf eine
Monatsrente von 1000 Euro netto zu
kommen müssen Beschäftigte derzeit 40
Jahre lang durchgehend
2844 Euro brutto im Monat verdienen
in Peru kommt das seit Wochen immer
wieder zu schweren Unruhen auslöser war
die Amtsenthebung und Verhaftung von
Präsident Castillo Anfang Dezember jetzt
hat die Übergangsregierung in mehreren
Regionen den Ausnahmezustand verhängt
das Versammlungsrecht und die
Bewegungsfreiheit sind für 30 Tage
ausgesetzt und die Armee darf eingreifen
um die Ordnung aufrecht zu erhalten bei
den Protesten sind bisher mindestens 42
Menschen ums Leben gekommen die
Demonstranten fordern sofortige
Neuwahlen
[Musik]
was jetzt kommt klingt fast wie aus
einem Fantasy-Roman es regt in der Tat
die Fantasie an und ist gleichzeitig
noch reine Fantasie es geht um seltene
Erden die wir brauchen für Handys für
Windräder für E-Autos und es geht um
eine Eilmeldung aus Schweden diese Woche
die die Beteiligten wie eine Sensation
verkaufen ein schwedischer
Bergbaukonzern hat so sagt er das größte
bekannte Vorkommen seltener Erden in
Europa entdeckt und zwar ganz im Norden
in Kiruna in der Nähe der größten
Eisenerzgrube der Welt
wie groß der Schatz wirklich ist und wie
lange es dauern wird um ihn zu heben
muss ich erst zeigen klar ist aber
bereits jetzt wie sehr wir abhängig sind
von den aktuellen Lieferanten seltener
Erden und wie sehr wir das ändern müssen
peter Kurz
mit Vladimir Putin am Katzentisch sitzt
hier eine seiner Raubkatzen Wladimir
Potanin mit Sanktionen belegter Oligarch
Milliardär und Mitbesitzer von nordical
dem weltweit größten Palladium
Produzenten und zweitgrößten
nickel-lieferanten der Erde Palladium
steckt in Katalysatoren und ohne Nickel
könnte kein Elektroauto fahren
Russland und China beide versuchen ihre
strategische Potenz mit
Marktbeherrschung anzureichern China ist
global auf rohstoffjagd und größter
Förderer von selten erdmetallen für ihre
Aufbereitung hat das Reich der Mitte
praktisch das Monopol ohne Seltene Erden
läuft kein Windrad keine Energiewende
eine vom Bundeswirtschaftsministerium in
Auftrag gegebene Studie stellt fest die
Zahl kritischer meist importierter
Rohstoffe von denen deutsche Unternehmen
abhängig sind wächst im Jahr 2011 waren
es 14
2020 schon 30 Deutschland kann sich
durch den konsequentes Recycling auf
alle Fälle Ressourcen unabhängiger
machen gerade unser altprodukte bieten
eigentlich eine sehr große
heimische Rohstoffquelle die wir nicht
vergeudenten sollten es ist Recycling
2.0 das hierzulande noch in den
Kinderschuhen steckt den Rohstoff Mix in
wasserplatten Mobiltelefonen und
Batterien wieder nutzbar zu machen so
wie bei der Hanauer Firma Umicore im
belgischen Hoboken recycelt sie auch
Kobalt und Nickel aus e-autobatterien
ziel ist die Herstellung neuer Batterien
in moderner Kreislaufwirtschaft das
erste wichtige Schritt ist
umfassendere Sammlung Erfassung von
Altprodukten und dann müssen diese
zuverlässig ausschließlich hochwertigen
Recyclingverfahren zugeführt werden
hochwertig wie in Freiberg Sachsen wo am
Helmholtz Institut daran gearbeitet wird
aus alten Energiesparlampen kleinste
Spuren von Seltenen Erden herauszulösen
mit Hilfe von Viren die die Stoffe
Angeln sollen
energiesparlampen sind bisher Sondermüll
unser Müll ist vielleicht der größte
Schatz für mehr rohstoffunabhängigkeit
vieles was früher gedankenlos
weggeworfen wurde wird immer wertvoller
hat der Gießener Professor geht für über
300 Deponien in Deutschland
hochgerechnet die Altdeponie die noch
nicht sozusagen die nicht mehr genutzt
werden die würden zur Verfügung stehen
und das sind erhebliche Mengen auf eine
Deponie in Baden-Württemberg auf der wir
gearbeitet haben waren 60.000 Tonnen
Metalle
allein das immer teurere Kupfer aus
alten Hausmülldeponien oder Bauschutt
halten zu bergen kann sich heute schon
lohnen jede Tonne zählt um wenigstens
ein bisschen Import unabhängiger zu
werden
Deutschlands rohstoffminen sehen so aus
heute hatten sie alle noch mal Land
unter den Füßen jetzt geht es erst
einmal über die Weltmeere
60.000 Kilometer weit die wichtigste
mannschaftsregatta das internationalen
Segelsports eisige Kälte raue See ein
Abenteuer mit dabei sind dieses Mal auch
vier deutsche darunter der Hamburger
segelstar Boris Hermann Startschuss zum
Ocean Race heute Nachmittag in Alicante
von dort geht es durch die Straße von
Gibraltar nach Süden Richtung Kapverden
die Länge der ersten Etappe
1900 Seemeilen
losfahren hat etwas Schönes sagt Boris
Herrmann wir erreichen jetzt auf seinem
Boot der malizia sind dort mit ihm
verbunden und nach Herrmann
wie fühlt er sich an der Auftakt zu
sechs Monaten Regatta
und die Mannschaft gibt alles also
besser könnte der Stadt sein
können Sie uns ein bisschen beschreiben
wie wir uns das an Bord jetzt
vorzustellen haben wie eng ist es zum
Beispiel auf Ihrer Yacht
ja
die arbeitet hier gerade und man sieht
den kartengrill
ist gerade hier draußen sozusagen durch
die Tür und schaut auf der Trimm okay
und ähm
sehen der Konkurrenten wir können ja
auch im Transponder sehen und ähm wir
versuchen ja und hier vorne unterhalten
aber jeder kriegt der
hinterher noch ein bisschen schneller
meine andere
Hermann wir kennen sie als einen der
allein mit der See kämpft in der
Vergangenheit bei der wohnte Globe jetzt
müssen sie sich sogar die Schlafsäcke
Teilen mit der Mannschaft was sind denn
die größten Unterschiede dieses Mal
20 Minuten kurz die Augen zugemacht ähm
das macht man aber gerne das ist kein
Problem
mit der Mannschaft des Boot ist so aktiv
bewegen kann
man als allein nicht und wir haben noch
den fünften Mann
versuchen die Geschichte dann auch
wirklich mit Ihnen zu teilen mit dem
Zuschauern und darüber zu bringen eine
eigene youtube-serie die ab morgen dann
live gehen würde wirklich danach
sozusagen
jetzt haben sie schon gesagt es wird nie
so sein wie man das erwartet ich nehme
mal an das macht auch so ein bisschen
den Reiz des Ganzen aus die Franzosen
haben heute einen Blitzstart erstmal
hingelegt es gab in der 50-jährigen
Geschichte dieser Regatta bisher nur
einen deutsches siegerboot wird sich das
dieses mal ändern
einfach
Punkte verteilt habe
also bis Juni konzentrieren alles geben
dann wünschen wir Ihnen alles Gute
danken herzlich fürs Gespräch und sagen
Mast und schotbruch Boris Hermann vielen
Dank
das Gespräch haben wir aus technischen
Gründen vor der Sendung aufgezeichnet
sie haben es gemerkt wir bitten die
schlechte Bild und Tonqualität von da
draußen auf hoher See zu entschuldigen
und Hannah du machst noch weiter mit
Sport ja und mit einer jubel-nachricht
von den deutschen Handballern nach dem
Auftakt sieht gegen Katar am Freitag
gelang es der Nationalmannschaft am
frühen Abend auch die starken Serben zu
bezwingen
2 Sieg im zweiten WM Spiel der deutschen
das DHB-Team feiert den Einzug in die
Hauptrunde gegen Serbien ist das Spiel
ein sehr schnelles mit spektakulären
Toren in der Offensive märz und Steinert
mit dem sogenannten Camper Trick
fast das gesamte Spiel liegt Deutschland
in Führung aber es ist eng auch weil
Serbien Spielmacher Lhasa Kukic zu oft
leichtes Spiel hat hier bringt er sein
Team auf ein Tor ran die deutsche
Deckung offenbart immer wieder schwächen
kann sich allerdings auf Joel Bier Leben
von den Rhein-Neckar Löwen verlassen die
deutsche Nummer zwei im Tor zeigt in den
letzten Minuten eine überragende
Leistung und vorne sorgt Lukas Mertens
für die Entscheidung der Linksaußen
verwandelt alle seine sieben Würfe und
ist bester Deutscher Torschütze
Deutschland gewinnt mit 34 zu 33 gegen
Serbien und geht mit breiter Brust in
das letzte Gruppenspiel am Dienstag
gegen
zum Wintersport die Deutschen
rotlerinnen und Rodler haben zum
Abschluss der Europameisterschaft im
lettischen Sigulda noch einmal drei
Medaillen gewonnen Anna Bereiter und
Dajana eidberger feierten in der
Einzelkonkurrenz Gold und Silber und
auch in der Mixed Staffel holte die
deutsche Mannschaft wenig später Silber
und auch beim zweierbock gibt's kein
Vorbeikommen an den deutschen Frauen
beim Heimweltcup im sächsischen
Altenberg sich hatten sich die Duos um
Lisa buckwitz Kim kalicki und Laura
Nolte die Plätze eins zwei und drei ganz
vorne und damit die Überraschung des
Tages Lisa buckwitz zusammen mit
Anschieberin Kia Lipper Heide durfte sie
ihren ersten Weltcup Sieg als Piloten
feiern
Glückwunsch und jetzt fehlt noch die
Frage was liegt kommende Woche an wir
sind Antworten von Kai Felix Jochens
[Musik]
ab Dienstag beraten Spitzenpolitiker
Top-Manager und Wissenschaftler beim
Weltwirtschaftsforum in Davos wichtige
Themen in diesem Jahr der
ukraine-konflikt und seine Folgen die
Risiken der Globalisierung und die
Bekämpfung des Klimawandels rund 2500
hochrangige Teilnehmer werden erwartet
am Freitag wird die Internationale Grüne
Woche in Berlin eröffnet die weltgrößte
Messe für Ernährung Landwirtschaft und
Gartenbau findet in diesem Jahr wieder
in den Messehallen statt nach zwei
Jahren corona-bedingter Abstinenz mehr
Ausgaben für Energie und Dünger bereiten
den Bauern sorgen Ressourcenschonung und
nachhaltige Landnutzung stehen auch
deshalb besonders im Fokus
am Sonntag wird China das traditionelle
Neujahrsfest feiern mehrere hundert
Millionen Menschen werden durchs Land
reisen um ihre Verwandten zu besuchen
überschattet wird der Feiertag durch
eine beispiellose corona-welle
unabhängige Forscher gehen davon aus
dass sich zuletzt fast 4 Millionen
Menschen pro Tag neu angesteckt haben
die Sorge ist groß dass das Neujahrsfest
diese Entwicklung noch verstärkt
und jetzt der Ausblick aufs Wetter und
das bleibt größtenteils ungemütlich
morgen im Westen weiterer Regen oberhalb
von etwa 300 Metern Schnee in der Mitte
und dem Südwesten gibt es im Flachland
einzelne Sturmböen die Höchstwerte
liegen zwischen 3 und 8 Grad in den
nächsten Tagen zeigt sich die Sonne
öfter aber weitere Schneeschauer sind
dabei es wird kälter bei -1 bis plus 6
Grad
das war unser Sonntag hier im heute
journal herzlichen Dank dass Sie dabei
waren ab morgen freuen sich hier Maria
taslomka und Heinz Wolf auf sie und die
nächste heute Express gibt es gegen 0:30
Uhr mit Christopher Wehrmann vom
gesamten Team auch dem hinter den
Kameras ein angenehmer Abend tschüss
[Musik]